this is what is left of bokeh in
guinea's maritime region
gone are the mahogany trees the rare
species of chimpanzees than the paddy
fields
the industrial extraction of bauxite the
ore for aluminum
has turned a once green oasis into
a lunar landscape void of life the water
is poisoned by
industrial chemicals this destruction
and pollution in one of the world's
poorest countries
is to extract aluminum to manufacture
where the automobile industry calls
clean green powered electric cars for
rich nations
as a result thousands of villagers in
bukit have been
forcibly displaced from their homes
among them mohamed suma
a rice farmer now living in the city in
what feels like a prison cell he says
there is nothing left but dust to eat we
have lost everything
we sometimes go two or three days
without food since the chinese took our
land our life is
misery human rights watch says
the displacement of people constitutes a
violation of human rights they hold
car manufacturing companies responsible
saying they have failed to address the
abuse with their
aluminum suppliers mining has taken
farmland
destroyed fields cut off water sources
and coated houses and fields in dust
as guinea's mining industry expands the
government's capacity
to oversee the industry must keep pace
guinea has the largest reserve of
bauxite in the world
much of it is untapped it could be a
formidable source of revenue
for a country where most live on less
than two dollars a day critics of the
government accuse
politicians of turning a blind eye to
the environmental damage
in exchange of kickbacks
let's be clear we are a poor country we
are aware that mining companies are not
complying with the social and
environmental regulations
but it isn't so easy for us to shut down
this industry for their violations
last week the european commission voted
to ban the sale of vehicles that run on
gasoline or diesel by the year 2035.
electric car sales are already on the
rise
so is the demand for bauxite in trying
to solve
an environmental problem it seems
automobile and mining companies are
irreversibly harming the environment
altering this precious landscape
nicholas hawk al jazeera let's bring in
jim
wormington he's a senior researcher in
the africa division of human rights
watch he joins us on skype from
washington jim welcome
to the newshour i don't want you to name
and shame but how many car makers
protect the communities involved in this
industry
very few um so in the course of our work
we spoke to about nine of the world's
biggest car companies ranging from bmw
to ford to gm to toyota
and aluminum is really a blind spot for
the car industry there's been a lot of
focus on other materials that you need
to make
electric vehicles like cobalt and
lithium for electric batteries
but very little focus on the human
rights impacts of aluminum
and we think that needs to change
because the car industry has a huge
amount of influence
over mining companies and the sector
more broadly and if the car industry
starts to take the human rights and
environmental impacts of aluminum
seriously
so will mining companies there must be
vast areas
in the african countries we're talking
about guinea in our report there from
our correspondent nick hark
where given climate change and global
warming the last thing we need
is more tens of thousands of
square kilometers of land being
turned over and left as it is when the
industry has finished or does the
industry
make the land good and return it to what
it was before
yeah it's an extremely difficult
question because of course
in a country like guinea which as your
report said is is one of the world's
poorest countries
the revenue for mining in the
government's eyes is something that
could be really essential to the
country's development
but at the same time the mining
companies and the car companies that
that ultimately use the material
have an obligation to make sure that if
mining is going to happen
it needs to happen in a way that
actually meaningfully benefits the
communities and the environments
where mining is happening and what we're
seeing in guinea at the moment as you
said is we're seeing a huge amount of
land
that communities have relied on for
generations being destroyed and very
little government oversight of how
mining companies actually act
so once land has been taken it's not
returned to the families who
who used it previously it's not
rehabilitated so that they can use it
again for farming once mining has
finished
and it leaves this kind of devastating
moonlight landscape
that really as you say is just a scar on
on
on the environment and so that's where
again we see the role of car companies
is putting pressure on the government
and on mining companies to drive up
standards
here's the thing that i don't understand
jim you were talking there about
electric vehicles so-called evs
but the demand for aluminium is going to
double between now
and the year 2050. how can that be as
the world does
move perhaps too slowly towards more of
us driving electric vehicles i mean the
car manufacturers behind evs
their green credentials are inside their
product and we're told it's
super lightweight it's super flexible
it's super strong it's good for the
planet it's all sustainable
and yet the demand for aluminium is
going to carry on going up and up and up
yeah and that's the contradiction with
many new technologies that we need to
fight climate change
including electric vehicles the reality
is that they're going to produce
from raw materials that rely on mining
we see that with aluminum we see that
with cobalt we see that with lithium
and it's the story that the car industry
isn't very willing to tell which is that
as they build more and more so-called
greener vehicles
they need more and more materials that
come out of communities and come out of
land
and so what's essential as that
transition happens
is that we all have a conversation about
how if we're going to have more mining
we can have mining in a responsible and
human rights protecting way
and that i think is going to be one of
the biggest questions that we uh
you know as a as a group of people have
to answer in the next 30 40 years
jim thank you very much jim wilmington
they're talking to us from washington
thank you very much